Now before I take the sigma, let me
actually take it the playground playground that tensorflow so you can
see why you would use other activation functions.
Let me tell you what we were why we're looking at here.
First this is the neural network.
this entire section
you have your features your input Dimensions if
we use tensorflow terminology.
your hidden layers
now
there is no hard rule or formula
for choosing the number of hidden layers.
but for most problems
two hidden layers is sufficient.
for most problems
or at least numerical problems data, that
is numerical and
Like if you're doing regression.
for that so for majority of problems, this is this is
this architecture's sufficient for things like pictures and
sound bites or text. No you do
you definitely more elaborate neural network, and
then you have the alpha layer.
So this entire thing is your neural network?
Then up here we have.
the hyper parameters
Remember, we should hyper parameters are synonymous with
the configuration of the new network.
This will allow you to run this for.
different number of epoch so you can keep feeding your data
to the network to see
and how it's doing.
And then you have these hyper parameters, which allow you
to control.
how the model learned and
how to control it
s the overfitting
so we have we can choose the learning rate.
the regularization function
the regularization rate
and then here
to
illustrate
how effective and neural network is
They have chosen some very unusual.
Shapes of data. I mean, this is look at this look at what's
going on here.
This is supposed to be like a scatter plot. We have two types
of data two data classes.
The blue one is centered.
In the middle and the second class is surround again,
you're unlikely to see something like this in the real
world. This is supposed to be like a extreme example.
The point of this demonstration show you how a new network is still
able to classify.
the
two classes in the data set
Here's another one.
Here's another one. This is easier.
And there's another one. Yeah, I mean, this is look at this. This is
the point that what now?
I have to play around with this, but we can use a
Samuel law work.
to completely separate
these
observations
now, how do we
separate
we need to talk about regression for a moment.
If I come back to this slide if I go all the way to
up here.
This is supposed to be a picture that illustrates the application
of the general regression model regression is
used for.
modeling the direction of a data
and that's how you forecast. That's
an application of forecasting or others known
as a regress. It's called regression because
in a
forecasting model the observations should
regress towards this
line.
A regression model this is obviously not linear because well
it's curved can also be used to separate the data.
into two groups if in the case of a binary
classification
So this would be a polynomial model.
And the idea is to draw the boundaries or to
draw boundary.
Or rather model the boundary of the data set.
Of course, it won't be perfect. So yeah, I hope you can see
on my screen. We have some light green observations some like green data points.
in the second cluster
Conversely we have some of these.
Dark, green or turquoise if you like to call it in the
first cluster.
But the majority have are well partitioned.
now
here's another reason why you can never want to use a linear model for classification
because it's linear. It's a single
line. You cannot use a single line.
To partition a sea of data points
like the one you see here, like imagine if this were a straight line you could
not clearly.
delineate
this section
you can't also do this with our value
model either.
Unless of course.
You use multiple ready models. Let me let me demonstrate.
I'm going to return to the
first example
I will not change the hyper parameters.
And I will not change the neural network. I will
not change the configuration.
I'm gonna have to play.
and what I want you to look at
is
the animation in here
now what you're going to see is this epox are quickly going to increment.
like some sort of
time-lap
And with each Epoch another thing you will see here is that
is the loss?
And we probably care for the loss. We want
this to converge to zero and it will be animated here. So
if I hit let's let's watch what happens. Okay, so you want to watch
you want to watch this and you want
to watch this space over here?
and we want to see if we're able to use for
really U models
not linear
not polynomial. We want to see if we can use that
rally that L looking model four of them.
to delineate
the boundaries of these two classes ready
one, two three
All right. Look at the last function is already converging to zero you
see how it has climbed down.
It is getting closer and closer to zero. We
are not at how many epochs 100 200 I'm
gonna hit pause 236 epochs
watch what has happened.
You see these boundaries.
These are formed by those four.
value functions
1 2 3 4 you can see here. We have formed the
first.
Angle and this is the second angle.
Put these together.
and you're able to
you know separate these two
clusters of data.
Is it clear like has this example, have you understand what we're doing?
What if I had said? Okay, by the way, this is tan H.
I should have changed us to value.
Let me set this to rally and try again.
One two three, I'm gonna hit play so you can see it
still does a good job.
Obviously the corners are sharper.
But that's what really does.
What if I would set this to linear?
and hit play
it's not able to.
Because there's nothing linear about the pattern of this data.
Let's try this other one.
and I'm going to use
A value again, and I'm going to hit play.
And sometimes you actually have to restart this 4 to work properly. So I'm
going to
hard refresh this
Try again.
There we go.
You can clearly see the value right now.
And for something like this, well, you need something that
is more curved like 10 age.
I hit play.
This might take a while longer.
so the loss is
a climbing
it's
consistent
I think I'm gonna have to a hard refresh.
To run this again.
So 10 age can hit play once more.
I remember this example always takes a bit longer.
But it is ultimately able to see you
know.
separate
these two classes
Okay, look at the loss is is dropping. It's
getting closer and closer to zero very slowly, but it is
still not good enough.
That this let's let it run a little longer.
It's 300. Is it going to go down to 200?
Look at that. Look at that. Look at that.
We're almost 1,000 epochs.
and
the test loss is kind of stuck at 300.
So what we might have to do is play around
with these hyper parameters like
change the regularization rate.
Even just a bad size.
But it's kind of oh look at that. Hold on.
Hold on what something's happening?
It is it's dropping again. It's dropped some more.
That's 1500 epochs.
I'm gonna I don't know if I should keep running this.
But it is it's done somewhat. Well, I mean the Tesla
is still not.
Good enough if we wanted to get closer to zero.
But clearly we want to use this activation function.
I think we had pause here.
But yes had I played around with this
with the hyper parameters. I could have gotten
it to perfectly.
You know separate the two classes.